depuis deux jours 20 16 août au sillonne
tout le secteur de montceau-les-mines
son ex compagne sa fille de 7 ans et son
fils de trois ans disparus depuis cinq
jours
toute la journée ils diffusent cet avis
de recherche dans l'espoir de trouver
des témoins voilà je voulais juste
savoir si vous les aviez bu et si je
pouvais affichée l'avis de recherche
vincent il ya même décrit le modèle du
véhicule dans lequel sophie yumi et liam
sont et avant de disparaître
une citroën saxo grise son inquiétude
grandit d'heure en heure il n'y a plus
aucune trace de ses deux enfants et de
leur mère depuis jeudi soir là des
traces d'activité sur son ordinateur
jusqu'à 17h30
et depuis la brillante une nouvelle aile
a présenté des forums on peut pas là
géolocalisé faut que tout le monde
connaisse leur visage et puis surtout si
vous les voyez appeler le 17
vincent hitoto a aussi créé une page
facebook pour que l'information soit
relayée sur la toile
il retourne même un régulièrement au
domicile de son ex compagne à saint
romain sous gourdon près de saint
vallier pour vérifier qu'elle ne serait
pas repasser par là je vois pas pourquoi
elle m'appelle pas à quoi elle ma fille
pareil elle se servir d'un téléphone je
vois pas je comprends pas c'est logique
les gendarmes ont lancé les recherches
ils ont survolé la zone du bassin minier
en hélicoptère notamment le canal et les
trous d'eau au cas où la saxo grise
serait accidentés sans succès
la brigade de mâcon lance un appel à
témoin les investigations sont en cours
on fait un certain nombre de
vérifications que ce soit des recherches
au niveau de local ou
ou des groupes en fonction des
différents éléments qu'on a et aucune
piste
à l'heure actuelle les privilégiés pour
joindre les enquêteurs vous pouvez
composer le 03 85 22 97 16 les gendarmes
continuent leurs investigations tout
comme vincent qui va élargir ses
recherches